Hello folks,
we are back live.
Uh the plan for today is to work on
vectorization.
Specifically,
I got to figure out why the current
version is deadlocking.
I got to add multiffold buffering.
Got to do some profiling.
And we do want to figure out how to
buffer CUDA transfers as well. These are
our goals.
Also, this run is kind of funny. Um,
this is just like Platin Coder.
So, this is the Perf gap between Platin
Coder and the full architecture.
But the funny thing is that this right
here, this was the soda from puffer um
puffer two I believe.
I believe this was like the soda from
puffer three somewhere around here. So
progress.
Oh no, from puffer
I forget. No, I think this was from
puffer three was around here. Maybe
four.
Progress.
Anyways,
So this here was important, right? This
is the um pinned memory Alex.
And then the question was why we were
getting deadlocks.
And lovely, love. We reboot this
container real quick.
Probably have to do. Yeah,
we're going to see how hard
vectorization is to get right.
Hopefully, it should not be too bad.
Oh, it is totally slow. Why am I using
this thing, man?
I've been wondering for the last like
week or two why my term has been slow.
This goes TTY. That thing is freaking
slow somehow.
Okay, so this thing runs.
Let's rerun setup just in case.
Yeah, that that's super obnoxious.
It actually does lag.
in that case, let me review the design
of this thing.
You just um
your comment on Elon's l which what did
I write? Oh yeah, the long one.
I don't know how it is that he doesn't
have the context for that given that he
was involved like I forget when he
stopped being involved with Open AI that
like he had a lot of exposure to the
Dota stuff or not. Um
but like you are just going to end up
with a weird version of of that.
And it's not going to work if you try to
do it without like specific training.
You're not going to prompt the damn
thing to like play League.
Yeah. Um
like honestly if you we read one paper
in RL you read the open AI5 paper
because like the open AI5 paper just
essentially it's defense against the
dark arts in some sense like you see how
simple this paper is and then you see
all the [ __ ] that academics come up
with that like that doesn't even work on
simple problems and like this honestly
was the most influential paper on all of
my work.
There's a lot of stuff I've had to
figure out on top of it, but like this
was the core,
If you're going to train frame by frame
on the actual game, yeah, you can do
that. All you're going to do though is
you're going to come up with a well,
like you're going to have to do RL.
You're not going to just generative
model the damn game. No way. So, like
you're just going to come up with a
vastly more expensive and stupider
version of this.
Actually, I think that there was like
there's even a Chinese um MOA where they
did like a mini version of OpenAI 5 with
even like less resources. They did it
with like Han or something. So, you're
literally just going to have gotten
crushed by Open AI and then like some
random couple like Chinese groups as
well that still work on games.
Like cool, I guess.
Honestly, that's not the uh the new
frontier though. The next frontier for
RL in my mind, it's always been like get
it to play an MMO
and we'll talk.
But the thing is like even if you get
the thing to work with a big pre-trained
model and like plus some fine-tuning,
the conclusion is completely different
from if you get it to train from
scratch.
Large model plus you can do it,
but like it's just it's woefully
inefficient. Actually,
if you want to see somebody who actually
has a chance of doing this, um, Pim
replied to that genu general intuition
guy.
They actually have enough data that they
can train across a ton of games and get
like a pretty good baseline model,
but it's still it tells you different
things, right?
Okay. So, there two there are a couple
problems here I'm seeing with this
Yeah.
FBR.
Yeah. It's the intermediate must do
steps. It's like external knowledge is
what it is.
But I like I intentionally don't really
work on that area ice because like
the stuff I work on is it's stuff you
can actually do on a reasonable compute
budget. Like these graphs here,
each of these graphs, this is 650
billion observations. This is over a
pabyte of data. So I have like way more
data here than is used in all of
training of any of the language models
and I can do this on one server.
like you can kind of get the sense I can
get completely different insights out of
the style of work that I'm doing without
even being compute constrained versus um
what you're going to be able to do with
large models where you kind of
fundamentally need the compute.
Okay, I think we need to figure out
trying to think how I want to even
formulate this cuz there's a thing that
I need to Oh,
Uh, you're going to have to write papers
that suck.
Typically, getting papers accepted
requires writing papers that suck.
kind of an awkward. So, what I'm trying
to figure out how to do for reference
right now, folks, um, we have this basic
vectorization
and I want to add like multi-stage
buffering to it. So, it'll go through
the first chunk of M's and the second
chunk of MS and the third chunk of M's.
That's pretty easy, but I want to do it
async.
And there's like the CUDA device.
Hang on, let me think. I just I have to
think about what I want to even do
clearly and then I can figure out cuz
it's basically just a couple sync
mechanisms I have to look up
I see.
Okay. This is not bad.
Kind of tough
sub millisecond songs.
Going to run with 14. Is it a tiny? Oh
yeah. 200 params.
200 params. You can almost run that like
you can almost run it like that fast on
CPU.
Honestly, at that scale, you're probably
better off doing evolution.
models can get IMO gold. They can solve
any games. That is not true.
That's not remotely true.
Ask an IMO gold medalist to come up with
like strategies for like Dota if they've
never played it or something, they're
screwed.
If I get this done in time. Yes, Roger.
And provided I think I'm allowed to do
that, right? You're allowed to do um I
think you are allowed to watch content
like that on stream.
right. So, what I want to do Yeah. Okay.
I think I formalized how I want to go
about this.
Said about the intuitive side.
Um, the external knowledge is less so
strategies and stuff like that. ice. The
external knowledge is more so
it's like when we were trying to solve
Pokemon, right? And like they give you
text instructions of what to do next.
Like
you can't just train on the game being
unable to read and know what to do next
from there, right? It's stuff like that.
I mean, like
technically even stuff like the graphics
of the game informing you on what to do,
right? Like
or the text on what items actually do is
another good one. The thing is like for
a lot of these you can kind of just
brute force it with samples by trial and
error and that's actually totally fine
and often times more efficient. But for
stuff that's like really spread out
where you can't brute force it, then you
need some external knowledge. Which is
why I specifically say it should be 99.9
plus% probably more than that RL and a
very small amount of highle guidance
Wait. 10x your LLM results with LM.
What? What does that mean?
Yeah, because I don't want to invest
time in getting good at using LLMs
because I think it's a [ __ ] way to go
about programming.
You're basically managing out
and in a year or two when like the like
little bit of control scaffolding you're
doing
is automated because it's really [ __ ]
easy. You simply have no idea what
you're doing, no idea about what's going
on at a lower level and no value
whatsoever.
Passing unit test does not mean your
code is an ass.
Some of the like some of the people I
know who write the worst [ __ ] code
I've ever seen have tons and tons and
tons of tests.
It's still a buggy mess.
There is no substitute for simplicity
and there's no objective way to test
simplicity.
Ultimately, I'm simply choosing to bet
on myself.
Like, it seems basically impossible.
That's a bad bet.
Like I'm not going to ask it to write me
a piece of code here, right? Like I'm
literally just I'm going to use this as
fuzzy docs.
Welcome, Kvert. Yeah,
I asked the other day about
multi-objective. You can already do it.
That's very different. I want to rank
preferences in action spaces via GP rank
preferences in action. GPI
Do you have an example of like the
problems you're interested in?
Because currently the best way to do
multi-objective is goal conditioned.
Um, it dep I'd have to see your problem
formulation to see if it makes sense.
You can absolutely use Puffer for
research. It's just like it's uh more
complicated than clean RL but way
simpler than SP3 and a thousand times
faster than either of them.
And there's convert on all three
platforms.
Uh we're going to do vectorization stuff
today.
honestly.
Roger, that would just be called a
parenting failure more than anything.
Like LLMs are not inherently bad.
Actually, they're quite good.
It's just people doing stupid [ __ ] with
them. Welcome off market. Hang on. Let
me at least like let me finish this
thought and finish this query first
because this is actually a kind of a
complicated thing. Um,
Sorry, I'm fraud. I meant I want to rank
objectives
and construct a PTO front of good
policies.
Oh, okay. I want to rank objectives and
correct
PTO front of good policies based on that
ranking. Currently that is done by
waiting.
I don't know what you mean by waiting
orcalarization.
Um
you can very easily do that now. So
hyper one very simple way of doing that
right at the moment without changing
anything about the algorithm. So you
could imagine that you have a bunch of
objectives defined in your environment
and um you know the policy might learn
to complete one or the other and then
you have a reward function that has a
few different components related to
different things in the environment. You
can run a hyperparameter sweep that
includes the reward coefficients,
right? And then you can track in the
logs you could track the completion
rates of different objectives. Um and
then you could map essentially all the
different runs that you've done with all
these different waitings of rewards uh
into the ordering or the you know the
total score however you want to do it
across all these different tasks. This
is actually something that we do quite
often uh for you know our own work like
this is pretty much one to one with how
we tune complex environments.
Yeah.
So, the problem with doing everything in
CUDA like that FBR is um you're not
going to have a fun time with complex
ends.
I'm pretty sure at least to be fair, I
have not gone through the effort of like
port neural MMO to CUDA to see what
happens, but I'm pretty sure that if you
have a full game with a whole bunch of
branching logic in it, um it just will
not be fast in CUDA.
It calls like a ton of syncs.
different type of sync, but a ton of
sinks.
Um,
yeah, parse this in the video. Yeah, you
can ask me more stuff about this if you
want as well. Like, this is why I
stream, but if you go just take a look
at neural MMO for instance, like that's
an end where we have a few different
reward coefficients and we sweep the
coefficients themselves. We only have
one like overall objective that we
monitor in that because we made a joint
objective out of multiple distinct
objectives to give us a single real
number metric of performance. But you
know you could equally as well use this
for multi-objective like in neural MMO
there's a profession level and a combat
level and we just define performance to
be the minimum of your profession and
combat levels. But you could very easily
come up with something, right, where
like you tune one way or the other and
you see, you know, how good you get in
one objective versus another as a
function of reward coefficients,
stuff like that. Hey, Jess.
So excited to do do everything real word
to get the drain drone demo working.
I'm new to RL, but I want to contribute
to puffer labs
on puffer.ai.
Did I add the guide there?
There's ice. Yeah. So, this there's the
guide here. There's this like getting
started thing. And then um there's also
for educational resources.
These two guides are a good place to
start.
My ex
Okay, so this wrote me way more [ __ ]
than I wanted.
Let me see though.
Okay, so you allocate
This is going to be allocated on CPU.
This is a CUDA malic to GPU.
We're not going to worry about the CPU
fallback yet.
If ever, honestly,
we might just do it so that the C++ back
end is GPU only cuz like why the [ __ ]
not? You can use PyTorch CPU fallback
otherwise.
pre-existing stuff to more exist
realistic environments. Definitely look
into how we do our environments then
because the way we do everything makes
it super super fast like you know two to
five million step per second training in
puffer 3 and ideally up to 10 million in
puffer 4.
this axis when I see an axis like this I
immediately consider all results
invalid.
This is not a uh a reasonable number of
steps to be doing research with.
I don't know. I would just go like if
they have some grid type ms that you can
actually scale up to be appreciable
tasks like these things are a few
hundred lines to implement and you can
train like this axis can be billions
very easily.
So you can really test whether something
works or not.
So how do we actually use
multi-objective environments is the
point.
Yeah. You just you basically figure out
an environment that you'd like that
you'd like to use, right? Look at the
way that we build our M port something
over and then you can very very easily
have the like the largest scale training
results on any multi-objective
environment out there if this is how
slow everything is.
Hyper let me show you something. This is
neural MMO. This is neural MMO 3, right?
These are 650 billion step runs. This is
our hardest environment.
So we do I mean this is same order of
magnitudeish as like all of Dota.
We just do like massive massive amounts
of samples. And this is on one server.
You don't have to do something this
crazy, but like I mean as a standard
we're typically running M for like few
hundred million at least. Doesn't even
take long and a few hundred million will
be a couple of minutes very often.
The harder environments are billions.
If they're doing 0.2 2 mill steps, then
what's going on is like
you're just working on very easy
problems basically,
which is it makes sense if you look at
the M's. You're just like you're working
on very easy problems and if your stuff
is that slow, like you're probably not
even running hyper pram sweeps. Very few
papers actually do. Um you're working in
very very low batch regime as well,
which is crazy unstable and
inconsistent. It's just not a good way
to do research.
Yeah, I mean it's kind of crazy just the
gap in how we do our research in puffer
versus everything else. Like
I don't know like 0.2 million. That is
and is that like five or six orders of
magnitude gap? Yeah. Like that's crazy.
Would
you attempt to go over the math
equations on page seven?
Multi-
effective tool kit RL.
What this
Yeah, I don't exactly understand this
either, man.
I get roughly what they're trying to do,
right? They're trying to mostly define
like this is diversity
given a set of different weights.
I could go over this. This would take me
a while though, dude.
It would take me quite a while to go
through their like what they mean by
this.
This does look like some What's this? V
F equals V. I don't know what V is here.
Yeah, I'd have to go over this in quite
a bit of detail, man. This wouldn't be
quick.
Uh, congratul
a few colleagues that like want to do
stuff on it there. Like there's just
some engineering that has to go into it
to make it fast
because like the base env is decently
fast, but then all of the rappers in
Python are just god- aful slow.
You really need your environments to be
at least a few hundredk steps per second
per GPU in order to make um appreciable
progress.
All gods. Oh, Roger. But that's not my
forte. Like my playbook is probably it's
80% engineering, 15% basic science, 5%
stumbling through math.
Like it's like my weakest the weakest
thing in my toolkit.
I do stuff occasionally. It just takes
me way longer to stumble through things.
Multi-objective value function. What the
heck? They have a multi-objective value
function.
That's kind of wonky. you have to define
um explicit objectives.
If you're going to define a value
function that has like different values
for different objectives explicitly,
it's way cleaner to just do goal
condition in my opinion.
The goal condition is actually pretty
easy.
You can get like one policy, right?
Doing tons of tasks in the same end.
All right. But I was looking at this
right.
Okay. So pin memory this is what I have.
This is just allocating to GPU.
You create a stream.
Oh, and you can just do this. That's
actually easy as hell.
That's so easy.
Okay.
So now I suppose the only question is do
I want to keep it one big block
of OBS on CPU?
this is so funny that they say this is
actually the preferred way in all
production RL systems when like
literally none of these things have
anything this sophisticated.
ever have a right to the same memory.
Okay,
this looks good to me, guys.
I think we can make this work. And this
is actually nice because I can test this
I can probably test this before it gets
too hairy.
Made promotion cleaner and chest is
learning better.
It took one bill steps for to figure out
some bug caused per spike after hovering
around.5 like should
bug hunting night. Very fun.
Actually I actually really like this.
This is like who does this is actually
really chill.
So because all we're going to have to do
here, right,
why do I have void star?
Oh yeah, because that's just how it
works, right?
Uh, is there anything else? Yeah, this
everything needs to be.
Yeah, everything needs to be
transferred. So,
I think this is fine.
No, Grock didn't cook, Jess. Brock was
fuzzy docks.
Yeah, this is fine.
So now we have allocated on GPU.
UDA me copy.
And we can actually do
host to device,
right?
And we can do the same exact thing here.
We can do cuda mem copy. This has to be
desk isve
actions
device to host.
And now the difference with this from
before,
this is actually going to be a very nice
piece of intra
because
look at this. We get to take
we just get to do actions. Hang on.
create environments right
create
I love when it says and the way every
high performance RL codebase does it
when there are literally zero code bases
that do this.
And that's almost it actually. Right.
I think that's actually it.
was your best one? They all suck, man.
Just don't overuse them.
if you're basically using it as docs
rather than trying to get it to write
code for you. Like look, am I trying to
get it to write logic here for me? No.
I'm trying to figure out what the
signatures are for like CUDA device
transfers and stuff because I haven't
used the like low-level CUDA API like
this before.
I'm not even like not even looking at
this crap.
Pretty much all I care about here is the
fact that I can do
do this. Hang on. Does this run?
Uh, okay. Okay, I need the
need the Juda trace
or the CPP trace.
Oh, I forgot to turn the lights on on
the flag today. Thank you for reminding
me, Roger.
I should get my deadlifts in in a
second. Anyways, we'll fix this bug and
then I'll go do that.
We're going to see how the deadlifts go,
though. The run. I went running this
morning today. It was just absolutely
awful and did not feel good at all.
I'm using Grock at the moment because it
got faster. Um, when Grock was slow, I
was using Sarah because it's fast.
Oh, you know what? I think I know what
this is.
Cool.
This runs
So now we have
we have our nice new vectoration and all
I have to do is I have to buffer this
and then we will have the fastest
vectorization out there by a mile.
That sounds pretty cool to me.
And I think this is totally the right
way of doing it as well. like the uh the
sample factory design is quite bad for
lots of ends.
This is going to be a way better design.
Way way better design
actually. You know, I really don't think
deadlifts are going to be a good idea
today.
In a world where intelligence isn't a
bottleneck,
um like problems are all solved
and there is re and scarcity is solved
and disease is solved and aging is
solved. Everything is just solved.
So until then, planning on the LLMs
doing everything for you is just [ __ ]
stupid.
If you're like, "Oh, intelligence isn't
valuable. Let me find something else
that is." No, there's nothing else
because the thing is most of the soft
skills are around like trying to manage
intelligence, which goes away if you
think the LLMs are going to be smart. So
yeah, it's literally it's just like most
of like the oh let me like assume the
LMS are going to do the deep technical
thing is just like saying I'm going to
be lazy and be completely worthless and
not actually bother trying to understand
anything ever.
That's why the discussion is just it's
stupid.
All right, let me go use the restroom,
turn the lights on, get more coffee.
I could try
I'm going to try one deadlift set today
because occasionally I'm wrong and
occasionally like the strength is just
fine even though I feel like crap um
running in the morning. So, if that
doesn't work though, I will just abandon
that for today. We'll do that tomorrow
and I'll just do my weighted pull-ups
today.
Maybe some rows. We'll see.
I'd be back.
Uh, nothing is ever inevitable, FBR.
Like, why the [ __ ] don't we have fusion
working by now? It's cuz it was
inevitable and then people stopped
working on it.
Same thing's happened many times
throughout history. It's only inevitable
if you are actively freaking doing it.
Get back.
So somehow
I normally run like near 10k in the
morning. I couldn't even do five
properly this morning. I just felt like
super nauseous and out of breath for
some reason. It was weird. But
apparently
my muscles did not get that message.
That's 375 for five. Just fine.
Was hard, but no harder than it was last
week.
Weird.
All right,
we do um
buffered vectorization now.
laws against patenting things in the UK
classified as a worldchanging discovery.
You can uh you can join us in the US,
the real country,
as the stupidest law ever. Like way to
go completely disincentivizing
any sort of actually important
invention.
Real country for now. Agree. We are
completely taken over by Canadian geese
here.
I've got tens of thousands of them. I'd
like to send them back to Canada. Thank
you very much. And uh exchange them for
some harp seals.
Do need Are they tasty?
They don't seem like they'd be tasty.
They're
You eat the Canadian keys,
huh?
I don't even think you would have to
shoot them. I think I could literally
just run and grab two of them.
They just sit there.
They're eating all like the leftover
corn kernels from the harvest.
could bring back a goose for
Thanksgiving. Just say, "I brought it.
You cook it.
X premium some anniversary thing.
It's definitely hell of a lot more than
a dollar on this.
Oh, yeah. I did launch um
is it I did the cool thing from X lately
was that I got uh well, it doesn't
actually show me my own subscription for
some reason,
but um
where is it?
We launched this thing for companies. So
companies can just sub for 200 bucks a
month to get like entry-level support if
they don't want a minimum 10,000 a month
contract with us. So I figured it would
be a nice way to get like people doing
some amount of professional RL and
wanting to have a little bit of guidance
get something out of it for way cheaper.
We'll see how that goes.
Mini product launch.
It's the funniest thing. Kvert.
Basically, everybody's like, "Well, you
wouldn't go kill a goose, would you?"
It's like uh I am absolutely fine doing
that. I just don't want to have to clean
the damn thing.
Man, get
all right. This is not caveman chat
though. This is RL chat.
Tasty goose good. No, we do RL
RL hunting bot.
Yeah, we can train the bot to go catch
chins on Runescape.
All right, let me think how we're going
to do this buffer transfer thing.
a local rabbit from the park grew up.
All right, that's kind of messed up.
Like
there's a total difference between
having like, you know, this is the pet
rabbit and this is the game for dinner.
Oh yeah, I I do not believe them when
they say that about domain
randomization. They're doing it wrong.
I've seen some I've seen the robotics
code. They're obviously just doing it
wrong.
They use RL games and [ __ ] for training.
These are really shitty libraries
trying to think how we want to do this.
So
We can probably do it based on buffer
index.
Dude, there's one of these.
How is that relevant here? There's
literally one vaccruct.
Oh.
Um, not really.
We're never memory bound anyways. I
guess it can help with caching, but
that's like pretty minor compared to
everything else that we do.
Can I do this?
I think I can.
Do we include the CUDA runtime?
Okay, this is fine. So we allocate
streams.
So we create like this and then this is
going to be
and
back dreams
I right
Now we do int buffer,
right?
So we just do int start
equals False.
I'm going to probably watch the uh
podcast on stream later if I have time.
Roger.
My current impression before watching it
though is like from what I knew about
Ilia and Sam, I I would have stuck with
Ilia in a heartbeat. Like
It's kind of good that he has his own
his own thing now that he can just do
whatever the [ __ ] he wants. Honestly,
way better than him even having like
just staying at Open AI or whatever.
Yeah, Sam is like the YC and Quora guy
and Ilia is like Alexnet second author
and seek to seek first author and like
probably like one of the most brilliant
best spoken people I've ever met.
Oh, okay. [ __ ] This is going to be This
is kind of awkward, right?
Yeah, we can still do this for now.
Yeah, we can still do this and test it.
And then we're going to have to go to
the send receive API.
No, convert nerps nearly killed me last
year. So, I think I'm taking uh I'm
taking a pass on that.
Literally took me an entire year to get
back in like about the same overall
physical shape.
I think I'm slightly weaker than I was
back then, but also a a bit lighter and
leaner and also a bit faster in running.
overall about what I was before that.
was in the hospital with pneumonia for
five days, dude. 105 fever when I got
there and like less than one full lung
to breathe with.
If I hadn't been in such good cardio
shape at the time, I would have been
dead.
Why do we have this actions thing?
I need this.
included. I'm not hinting at some sort
of AI winter, dude.
AI is legit.
Like AI can simultaneously be legit and
there can also be like a lot of dumb
[ __ ] around AI from grifters trying
to make a quick buck.
Uh,
what's this like API?
Start.
Joseph nut paper.
I'd have to come up with something.
Well, because I didn't
that's not even correct.
Who's the most cracked puffer lip guy in
X who started some time ago?
Depends how long ago. Spencer's kicking
ass right now.
Uh Jess started way more recently and is
getting some pretty good stuff done with
chess.
Um,
bet didn't get like has not done stuff
at the same level as that, but he also
started with like literally no
programming experience. So, from where
he started, he's done some pretty damn
cool stuff.
Yay, it works.
Look at that. We can write some CUDA
calls without breaking things.
That that
So Bet did what did Bet do? I mean in
addition to all the advertising he does,
Bet did um
the best end is Enduro here.
Oh,
this is a pretty cool M, right? This was
like a way harder project than I
expected. I should not have given this
to a total beginner.
And uh this is a pretty cool M to watch.
Like
it's just like one of these like really
clear-cut superhuman.
We should ship a better model for um 40
for this. I think if we like reduce the
entropy it'll stop jittering so much.
You literally reward it for jitter
jittering with entropy.
So, it is possible.
Look, I make it way, way, way easier
than it was when I had to learn this
[ __ ] okay? It's still going to take
some work. I've made it as easy as I
possibly can. It's still going to take
some work. I'm not going to lie. But
I've put together a pretty damn good set
of resources for anybody who actually
wants to learn.
And they're like focused on teaching you
[ __ ] not just like [ __ ] with you and
wasting your time.
All right, so we got uh basic vec. So
the next thing we have to do with this
is the send receive API.
Let me explain this real quick before we
uh we do this also so I can get my own
thoughts right.
Actually I have this in the Python.
All right. So in um in the current uh
Python buffer 3 version we don't
actually use ve.ststepped. Okay. We have
a two-part API.
There's this vec receive which gets
observations
and then there is a ve send that sends
actions back.
And the idea between this is you can
send actions back and this can be done
async, right? And then this receive is
not going to be getting data from the
same M's as you just sent actions back
to.
Yeah, I can't even beat like the 1500
ELO bots, dude.
I'm bad at like virtually all games and
all puzzles.
We have multiple chess people in here.
It seems perfect. We have two people who
can go look at Jess's chess thing and
tell if it's if it's uh tell us if it is
any good. Because honestly, chess is
going to be probably like the best
selfplay ends, right?
Because like keep in mind, we're going
to do it without search. So like
selfplay chess without search is
probably pretty hard.
That's one of the bigger projects going
on right now.
If Jess is still here, um go ahead and
ask like what you need done. What he
needs done.
Oh yes, Discord. GG/puffer for all the
dev.
Also, since we have a bunch of new
people, good time to mention um feed the
puffer a star. He's hungry. Click star.
Feed star helps.
Well, everybody is better at chess than
I am.
Domain translation model. Cool. Welcome
to stream. We're currently building a um
we're building a C backend for
vectorization
and the big thing we're trying to do
right now is buffered GPU transfers.
Hey Jess, there you go. You just got
yourself some uh some high elo feedback
for your agents.
you're in the right place to play around
with RL. This is the
pretty much the only spot you can run RL
at home and actually just have it work
on very limited hardware.
Buffer is fast.
Buffer is very, very fast.
And so we need to add vex step. I
believe
I think the easiest way to do this is
just like
So,
this is uh a really really far cry from
chess Ice, but like
I think I kind of get the type of
insight that you develop when you get
better at chess. I have like a stupid
number of hours growing up on this MMO
called Dophus that's like tactical
fantasy chess on steroids. And I
remember that like over time you kind of
just develop this vision for like you
see what's just going to happen in the
future and your mind just automatically
discards all the stuff you don't need to
think about.
I'd imagine it's probably a pretty
similar feeling to that.
I know it's kind of a weird feeling. I
never got into chess. I tried a couple
times.
TPU support and libs like this. Um, so
the problem is TPU support at this point
basically means jacks and jacks can go
[ __ ] itself.
So
yeah,
I am actually, if you're interested in
that though, I am going to be doing a
Thanksgiving Day stream tomorrow in
which I'm going to be trying out Tiny
and um Tots or at least whoever runs the
Twitter account, who I'm pretty sure is
tot uh that'll look at it'll actually
like look at whatever benchmarks I
produce out of it. So,
Yeah. So, that would be um
you can probably get that out of a lot
of games, but they'd have to be like PvP
games. You're totally right that you get
like limited to one path though and
anything that's first is a predictable
AI.
Shut up for Twitch integration
neural MMO. We actually we just got soda
here uh pretty recently and you can look
at it in your browser.
It doesn't have all this the same number
of agents or anything,
but it is there is a playable version in
your browser that has the AI like this
is hands off, right? The AI is playing
it at the moment.
Uh, this is actually the hardest
benchmark we have by like at least two
orders of magnitude.
think neural MMO is by far the N that we
use to test like whether something is
actually better or not.
Any idea why why it's so hard? I mean,
play it and then play any of the other
M. Like, it actually has some pretty
like long-term reasoning and stuff
associated with it.
And there aren't other environments
where you can just drop a thousand
agents in and have them do anything that
like that's that sophisticated. Like
there's uh there's leveling, there's
armor, weapons, equipment, tools,
uh gathering stuff. There's market
agents can trade with each other.
There's a lot of stuff going on. Just a
complex end.
Yeah, we'll see. So, I believe him if
he's going to tell me that Tiny Rat is
like a better Jax. I don't know if it's
going to be It depends how much
low-level control it gives me, right? I
mean, he says it outputs CUD uh it
outputs kernels. So, like if it will
output actually like usable kernels that
I can paste in and then just compile and
run with those kernels bound to
anything, then that is awesome.
But we shall see.
What's a complicated RL that would have
a super fast percept computation?
I mean, neural MMO is pretty fast,
Kinbert.
Like the only thing right now limiting
neural MMO is um it has 1.7 kilobyte OBS
and uh the host device transfer kind of
gets you a little bit on that, but like
that this what I'm doing here is
literally going to fix that. Like I'm
pretty sure we're just going to
eliminate that completely
because I think technically you should
be able to get 32 gigs of uh of
transfer, right? Like 32 gigs a second.
So if I get anywhere near that, this
just doesn't become a bottleneck.
Hey, son of liberty. We're doing um we
are doing uh
async uh host uh async buffered CUDA
transfers in our vectorization back end.
So we're going to eliminate the overhead
from going back and forth from GPU to
CPU. That's the goal.
Pretty much it, isn't it?
Send back receive.
Try this.
What is the secret sauce for reaching
soda?
Mining.
We got a new mining based uh
architecture in puffer 4.
You only get that info on the stream
though.
And it's still going to be it's going to
be a while because Mingru is um we still
have to make the architecture fast. It's
going to be faster, but it's just harder
to optimize
since you're writing kernels. Have you
checked out XLSTM?
Uh Javier, we we just got soda with
Mingru.
I think XLSTM is too heavy,
but uh yeah, we like we got it with
Mingru. The problem with all of these
though is they're really obnoxious to
implement fast.
So I'm working on it and it will be
faster, but it's really obnoxious.
Yeah, sorry. That does not count as
hard.
I actually I have this idea um because
you know since I've been writing kernels
the insight that this has given me is
like the way that research works right
now is you have a whole bunch of uh
scientists who have no idea how to
program anything or how a computer works
just like trying different
architectures.
Um, and then you have a bunch of
overworked engineers being like, "How
the [ __ ] do I possibly implement this
thing fast?" Uh, you could probably come
up with some good architectures that are
just really easy to get uh max flops,
like max throughput out of. I think
that's probably a pretty promising way
to go, especially with smaller models
where like overhead is really hard to
optimize. You know, you could imagine
that we come up with a model that has
100k params that also runs at the exact
same speed as models run now, but is
using 100% GPU, right?
Hey, this still works.
Lovely. So,
uh now we need to async this.
I think we can just async this, can't
we?
What happens if I just do this?
It's so funny to me how this is like way
easier than the Python vectorzation work
I had to do.
Um, I have to read that thing. That
looks really cool. It's completely
insane. I don't know whether it'll be
useful to what I'm working on. I'm gen
I'm very suspicious of like EVO low rank
updates in general. I would suspect that
that's useful in LLMs because LLMs have
like really shitty RL. So, like the fact
that EVO is better actually just is
funny because it just means the LM
people are trolling. Um, I'd be
surprised if you beat like actually good
RL on models where you can do it, but I
have to read it.
17.
That doesn't do much for us, man. We're
not trying to get like
So, first of all, you can't get 300 mil.
Getting 300 mil SPS on that when you're
not just doing like the whole thing in a
kernel is very hard.
Like if you look at some of the kernels
I've had to be like I've had to write
lately.
I mean, heck, you know, you're not even
using really your GPU properly, I'd
assume, right? Like, you're probably
just doing your mat moles manually or
whatever.
Like, it's not using the tensor cores if
you're just writing a custom kernel and
like doing a mat manually. You're not
even using like the dedicated mat
um pores on your chip.
I mean, it's cool. And actually, you
know, if you wanted to look at like EVO
based stuff, that is kind of the way
that you would do it. Um,
like for EVO based stuff, I honestly I
think that some of that could even work
now if you made stuff just stupid fast.
And honestly, the egg roll thing that
they made like the doing low rank
updates is a really good idea. I don't
know why that never occurred to me.
But like the thing is if you want EVO to
work, this is where like you go get 100
milstep per second training
like you just accept stuff is going to
be more general but less sample
efficient in general.
All right. How did I break stuff by
doing this? Let me think.
How do you debug this [ __ ]
It's not that complicated
Oh, believe me, I love my break points,
dude. And if I need them, I will
absolutely have like I can get break
points into this stuff as well.
But at the moment, I'm making very small
changes. And like this is just for some
reason this thing is like I don't know
why this thing is uh above zero. That
doesn't make sense to me.
Didn't realize you had your thesis video
on YouTube. Just watched it.
Yeah, I uploaded it and it did pretty
well.
There's also the iceberg video on there
is a pretty decent piece of content.
Looked very different compared to back
then. I mean, I was all dressed up in a
tux
and I had not fought I had not spent two
years fighting like,
you know, a low-level
RL demons from hell.
Building is a tough one, Ratchwag,
because you have to make sure that the
agents can't grief the environment into
an irreversible state.
Building with a decay system works like
um if you think of like Rust or V
Rising, like those style of games have a
building system that absolutely would
work.
look better now.
I mean, I am pretty lean now. I'm leaner
now than I was then, for sure.
I would like to get a bit of the muscle
mass back on. I think that's going to be
the plan for the next training block. I
usually go to Florida for a couple
months in the like the coldest part of
the winter. I got to get some PT for my
shoulder because it just never healed
right. So, I don't know if I'm going to
get like shock on it or something, but I
got to get my pressing strength back so
I can train overhead press. And then, um
I also have to start squatting again.
And then I'm probably going to do like
um a pretty heavily hypertrophy focused
block while I'm doing that and see if I
can get some weight back on, but get it
back on lean.
And then I have to figure out how to
maintain my cardio well enough because
like it just sucks running in Florida.
There's not like really a point in me
trying to get like to really improve my
cardio there because the training just
sucks there.
Yeah, rat swag. You basically get like
2b2t type stuff
except like worse.
Think like um completely unregulated
Minecraft server.
Today I ran in a t-shirt and sweatpants
and I was hot.
It's also called
is also
there is a cool gym that I go to in
Florida. They have lots of good uh it's
like there's a local powerlifting gym
that's just it's just absurd. Um, I've
seen guys pull like 650 in there and
I've seen I think I've seen I think
three different women pull above three
plates and one woman pull like 400 in
there.
Oh yeah, Jess, where do you think like I
know about all the gaming, man? Like
where do you think I get all the
inspiration for all these M's and like
you know all this game RL comes from? To
be fair, the vast vast majority of my
hours are in a couple different MMOs,
but played other stuff too.
Way less now cuz work constantly. But
I've been playing Evans Shore lately.
It's been fun
giving me ideas for neural MMO 4.
Thinking off tomorrow. No, tomorrow we
have a special stream. Uh I'm going to
be trying Tiny Grad. We're going to see
how that goes.
I'm trying to figure out how I want to
do this
cuz
wait for all threads to initial. Ah,
you know what?
Yep.
That's it.
What I thought.
Do we learn? Yes, we do.
Boom.
Okay.
Uh, we're going to commit this so I
don't lose it because the next thing
we're going to do is a little sketchy.
Okay.
I do need to take some time off though.
Um
I don't know. I can kind of tell that
like my mental is just stuff's getting
hazier. It's like I can kind of tell
it's time for me to take more than an
hour, like a few hours here, a few hours
there off.
Uh,
but they're like just there a few more
things that need to be done, man. Like
it always is.
So, for now, I'm kind of just being
satisfied with taking a few nights off
here and there.
the design has to change a little bit to
support this.
So what we have right now is we have the
API the same but under the hood this has
to support like multiple different
buffers worth of ends.
I got to think about the way that I want
this threaded.
I know. So, rat swag, usually the way I
see it is like when I don't want to be
working, it's usually time for me to not
work because
I kind of just like with all the
exercise I do and the amount of like
stuff I crank out, I kind of just trust
that I have a ton of discipline in my
work. um not trust like I've kind of
like just I show it to myself
constantly. So whenever I'm like I don't
feel like working man I just go okay I
need a break because normally I want to
work so if I don't want to work I must
just be tired.
Oh Sanjam. Oh, and before I forget, I do
have to check.
I was expecting
one client inquiry.
Okay. So, the ways that we could do
this, right?
We don't really need to have multiple
blocks of threads, do we?
Like, we can reuse the same set of
threads.
No, kind of can't.
I mean, I can initially, but it's going
to get more complicated anyways.
Okay, so there are a couple things going
on here, right?
We'll draw this so everybody can
understand what's going on.
This is actually kind of complicated
just a little bit.
So we have
bunch of N's.
Okay. And then we want to go over these
in blocks.
And then here we have three
buffers
And then
what we want
is this gets like
OBS
Okay.
And then you have like your model.
Your model actually is going to just be
like taking in
obs and actions from different M's at
different points in time here.
But
the problem is how do we synchronize
this Cuz
like on reset, let's say on reset,
right,
you already have available
So what happens is when you get actions
here,
what really needs to happen is there
needs to be
Do you need an extra thread, I guess,
don't you?
Yeah, you're going to have to have an
extra thread.
Oh, yes.
Yeah, you do.
Damn, that's annoying.
Well, I have some idea of what I need to
do with this. So, we basically
we need to have an extra manager thread
here. And that manager thread is going
to be responsible for
uh for basically checking when CUDA
device transfers are done
and actually like starting up the end
computations.
Here's a diagram.
I'm going to use a restroom real quick.
I'm going to get more coffee
and I'm going to see if I can get a
second deadlift set and then we're going
to work on
casually taking a break. Pull 36 to 375.
Thank you very much.
I am not autistic.
I understand the mistake there,
but I am not in fact autistic.
You could be uh excused though based on
how I do things.
Python handle all this fast. No, Python
actually makes it way harder, Tim, and
basically impossible to optimize.
Uh
cuz I have
I got fives on there, right?
Let me see.
Yeah, I got a pair of fives on the end.
A 375.
Yeah, you can't see them from here.
My best ever was 410 for two, but that
was when I was over 15 lbs heavier uh
and with straps and with a belt. So,
the first set today was 375 for five. No
straps, no belt,
down 15 lbs. I only weigh like 170 right
now. I'm pretty light.
I managed like a I think like a 630 mile
a couple weeks back and uh you know some
decent five and 10k times
good PRs at least
we don't need that
and convert something
that is why I'm not going back to
nuripss
How much do I sleep? Not enough, man.
I'll sleep eight or nine hours and I
want like 11 or 12.
Widow Tournament Edition V
V4 75% with orange switches.
Not super clicky.
No numpad.
Don't need the numpad. Gets in the way
of your mouse with games.
Not that I'm playing anything
competitive these days.
This has been my favorite keyboard so
far. I really like how every time I buy
a new razor thing, it's actually like
tangibly better than the previous thing.
Like they actually keep improving their
products.
so this has to go to async
naga.
Uh, I've got a death adder v3.
I've used um goes with the MMO mice,
right? Yeah, I've used those a bunch. I
used actually the hex is a pretty decent
one. If you want some buttons but not a
ton of buttons, the hex is pretty
decent.
[ __ ] load of buttons.
Yeah. I don't know. It's like it depends
what you're doing. You don't always want
the buttons on your mouse hand.
I think at like the sweatiest I had some
stuff on the mouse and then I had like 1
through 7 Q through Y maybe.
Oh, and then you can do you can also do
shift modifier.
All right, enough of that. Let's get
this done. So, the thing that we have to
do here
or the threads.
All right. So, we have to do
Last thread
this
work stuff.
Are you kidding me? You use a naga for
work, dude.
You literally use like the MMO mouse for
work.
Just so everybody can realize how
ridiculous that is.
I I gotta show this real quick, guys.
Like,
is it
all right? That's what this mouse is.
Oh, yeah. And then this thread just has
to get its task, right?
So, this just has to be
Well, I mean, we can start by just
making Vex end.
Oh no, we want to make this a little
different, right?
So this is C thread step. So we can just
make this void C thread manager.
this thing.
Don't need this.
We kind of need to think about the
design of this thing
because
Okay, so these guys are no longer going
to wait on
numbum running threads, right?
Happy Thanksgiving. That will be
tomorrow. Good sir.
I think I just want to do um
I think I just want to do a circular
buffer, right?
So instead of adding numbum threads or
anything like that, it's just going to
we're going to add like tasks.
So all then we need is we need an index
and we need a tasks remaining
Cth thread manager also needs some stuff
to sync.
Yeah. So C thread manager is also going
to need a couple things to sync. Um,
C thread manager one's kind of awkward,
isn't it?
How do we do this without busy waiting?
That I guess I could do this busy
waiting to start.
It's really easy with busy waiting one
thread, isn't it?
Now, the only thing that's a little
tricky,
I think we need send streams.
And do we need um
Okay. So, we're going to get single
stream
and then we can just do ready, right?
Yeah. We just need to have a ready
thing.
but I think this is easier.
Okay. Yeah, I have an idea on the design
now. Yo, Peru,
we are doing some major stuff with your
code right now.
I am uh making it double or nfold
buffered and we are doing async CUDA as
well which if I do this correctly we are
going to completely eliminate the
biggest source of overhead in like
hyperfr
when did you learn CUDA? I didn't dude I
just kind of started doing it
like I don't know it's C that runs on
your GPU. How hard can it be?
I've done multiprocessing. I've done C
So, we're going to get rid of this numb
running threads.
trying something a bit different.
Hang on, let me see if you're doing the
exact same thing I am.
So, Peru gave me the um the initial C
thread implementation that I've been
working off of.
Where Peru
fan eval
to get each eval per emperor tight loop
of get action
back to batch independently.
Uh
Okay. So, let me explain what I'm doing
to you, Peru, since you know you did
this. Um, so what I am trying to do is
let's say you have 8K M's and you want
to split this into four buffers of 2048.
Then you reset all the M's. You have uh
all of the OBS available. You consume
the first 2048 obs by you know passing
through the model and then you
asynchronously pass the actions back to
those first 2048 m
and in the background that's going to do
it uh it's going to wait until CUDA
syncs. It's not going to force it to
sync. And when CUDA finishes syncing,
then it is going to step the M's.
And similarly, you know, you get the
second batch of OBS from the 2048 to
4096M,
you compute actions, da da da da, and by
the time that you get back to the first
set of environments, you're going to
have OBS already ready for you and
already loaded into CUDA. So the idea is
that if you do this correctly, you will
never bottleneck on transferring actions
to CPU or on transferring obs to GPU.
And then it's going to be very easy for
me to write a test, right, where I test
max steps per second throughput of this
vector implementation as well as max
bandwidth throughput of this
implementation.
And then this will basically be as good
as it can get. Like this is I think this
is the best architecture.
Each end will just run its own getit
action.
They all do CUDA ops.
No, that's a ton of tiny operations.
You don't want
you want a relatively small number of
threads compared to the number of M's
you have
and runs on get action and they're also
you got to remember they're writing to
the same stored memory so you're not
going to dot CUDA each observation
independently right that's a tiny little
transfer you're going to transfer to
CUDA in bigger blocks
number of threads equals number of
cores. I think it can be two times
number of cores in C. I think that the
numbum cores limitation is a Python
thing. Um but yeah, roughly, you know,
all right. So,
the first thing we're going to have to
do, we're going to we're going to remove
numbum running threads and we're going
to have
work tasks.
Uh away busy waiting wasn't really a
problem.
Running the environment. Yeah, I I need
that main thread for something else now
though.
So the main thread now Peru is going to
be used for um managing
Managing host device host syncs.
see if this makes sense.
Fetch add.
I can easily just do mod and remainder,
right?
So, we can just do I think I know how to
do this.
brother, explain what you're doing in a
simple way with example. Well, there's
not really an example because nobody's
doing this. Um,
what I'm attempting to do though is I'm
attempting to have something
that can simulate a whole bunch of
environments on CPU. And I'm trying to
come up with a way such that the data
transfers that go to the GPU are
buffered. So I'm never actually waiting
on data being transferred between the
CPU and GPU.
And this involves a mess of threading.
Hang on. Let me I have to figure out
this one thing first, which is how we do
how we do indexing. I think I think it's
not that bad. I think num ends, right?
Yeah. Yeah. Hang on. We can just do int
num ends.
work tasks
work index.
Yeah. So the way that this is going to
work, this is going to be kind of weird.
Um
you wait for this mutex, right?
and then
fetch sub explicit. So we want to do
and review one time your codebase.
Yes, it's just I'm in the middle of a
pretty fancy operation. I've tried to
explain it various times today. Um,
so the thing is that we have
we have a whole bunch of like remote
environments and these are simulated on
a bunch of threads in C and we have a
model that is going to be consuming data
from these. But the model's on the GPU
and the environments are on the CPU. So
what needs to happen is observations
come from here. They go from CPU to GPU
and they get to the model and then the
model is going to compute actions and
then it puts them onto CPU from GPU and
it's going to do this with all the
environments. Uh now the problem is that
this is overhead right this data
transfer is overhead. So what I'm trying
to do basically is split all the
environments I have up into a bunch of
blocks. Right? These are three blocks.
And the idea is that uh the model can
submit actions but not actually wait for
them to be synchronized to the CPU and
it can like go through all three blocks
and in the background these actions are
going to be being synchronized and the
environments are going to be being
stepped. So by the time you get from the
end and go back to the start then the
idea is that you already have
observations waiting for you uh on the
GPU and you don't have to spend time
transferring.
Yes, this is like the send receive tim
um it's not just doing it at a lower
level though because the Python
multipprocessing doesn't have a way to
also sync to CUDA. So pretty much the
the Python VEC just gets you the OBS on
the main thread and CPU. This is going
to have them already in CUDA for you
already on the GPU. So that's why this
is going to be way better. It's not just
like C versus Python. Way better
should be at least. I think that this
should get us close to like this should
get us pretty close to max transfer
speeds. Um, this is like probably the
most substantial PF optimization we can
do.
Kind of tricky though. So, the thing
that I think I need to do with this work
index.
Index.
So, it's going to be minus one for the
task.
Just as tough. Yes, it is.
But Roger, the uh the benefit here,
right, is we can train millions of steps
per second.
Not really potential. They're all dumb
models.
But what I'm trying to do right now is
we need to keep track of two atomic
indices.
Um
so what we let me think I if I can do
this it's if I were to write this
without this being thread based let's
try this. So we do um env and in int
equals work index
and then we just intasks
remaining
equals work index
uh divided by
something like this. Right?
percent
m
and then
passes
It's something like this, right?
And then in new work index equals
Yeah. So, welcome to everybody. What
we're doing at the moment is we're doing
um
we're doing the C backend for uh
environment vectorization and we're
doing it with buffered uh CUDA device
transfers. So this is going to be like
dramatically faster than any
vectorization backend ever done for RL,
including my own already
state-of-the-art one for Puffer Lib.
This should be a pretty big gain. If
you're new around here, it's all open
source on puffer.ai. AI be the puffer
star helps me out a ton.
So the problem is like how do you do
this? Like this is not atomic at all.
okay, maybe I'm going about this wrong.
So all we need to do
we need to know how many tasks are
remaining and we need to know
the current end index Hey.
Oh, let me think if this architecture
even makes sense because hang on.
You submit multiple work orders.
I think no, this still works.
Yeah, the design is still good. We just
need to figure out how to do this uh
this operation atomic
Right. Because this one didn't have to
be
didn't have to be circular before.
Right.
kind of need two indices. Yeah,
that's hard.
Yeah, this doesn't let you update it
unusually.
on. Maybe there is a way to do it with
one index. Let me think.
I think that you can do it with an end
index.
Yeah, I think you can do it with an end
index and a current work index.
something like Puffer Lib when I was 20.
Very easy. Honestly, if I had Puffer Lib
when I was 20, I probably could have
convinced Open AI to keep doing all the
RL stuff they were doing.
Do you want you in? All right. I have an
idea. This was fine.
I know how we're going to do it now.
That was a little difficult to think
about, but I think this is going to make
this is going to make sense.
This one is still race conditiony, isn't
it?
Oh, we just add the same bloody check
here.
this. Right.
I think something like this is about it.
You don't need this
and you do not need
We're going to get rid of this for now,
I think.
Okay. So now this is making a thread
manager
hard.
Okay.
I'm having so much more fun doing this
though than the stuff I was working on
yesterday. Like, oh my gosh, that's so
much better.
This is like actually cool. It's tough,
but it's actually cool.
I mean, this is like this is going to
end up being a 200 line piece of code
that just smokes everything Perfwise in
RL
actually is going to just smoke
Anything?
They sidestep it by writing their Ms on
GPUs. So they go, "Oh, look, the GPUs
are always loaded." But then they're
using the GPUs in like the least
efficient way possible.
The result is garbage.
Orbage.
uh none of these mess with end vindex
actually.
Uh actually literally nothing is messing
with this. This doesn't need to be an
atomic,
Yeah, we'll leave it.
I'm not entirely sure.
I put something so they stop freaking
like running into it super hard, but
they still like
And then you have to wake
uh
Yeah, I actually don't think this is
right.
Okay. So, this is going to be I think
this chunk.
Yeah. So this chunk is fine, right?
You do an async copy.
do I need an inbox and outbox type
thing?
Literally, there are zero 1 mil plus
FPS. But basic cleaner like none of
these are this fast.
Let me think if there's a clever way to
do this or not. So, it's like
there's a stream that's going to be used
to send actions
to the GPU or to the CPU rather.
I can probably let's try it with one
stream for now.
Uh so this is when we do this chunk All
right.
Yeah. And now we need to know when these
are done
Then uh now this is where we can copy.
Yes, we're getting closer.
This is where we copy this.
See,
Like I said, we'll get harder before it
gets easier.
All right.
So,
and now it's actually quite easy
because now it's just manager outbox.
It's like vex send.
Yeah, this is all vexend has to do.
And now all vec receive has to do
is
well it has to [ __ ] busy wait now
which is obnoxious.
Okay, so this actually becomes very
simple.
And now the only
other than obviously debugging this
mess, the main problem we have not
solved.
The only problem we haven't solved is
knowing when our obs are ready
on uh CPU.
Let's just make this a little easier on
oursel.
So,
So
the actions are ready on GPU
then
actions already on the GPU.
and we launch the new job.
If OBS are ready on the CPU,
How is one stream going to avoid the
weight? What
are you only working with two dudes? I
don't know what that means, dude.
Okay. So, yeah, the only thing we don't
have right is we need to know when Yeah,
this OB's already on CPU.
Oh, you know what? I bet we can do I bet
we can actually do this as an atomic
fetch on work index.
Yeah, we totally can.
How are you managing your product? Do
you have some Trello Jira? Nope.
That's all bloat, dude.
There's like
no reason to do that [ __ ]
literally on any given day, I just like
I pick whichever of the top three or
five most important things there are to
work on and like whichever of those
seems most interesting to me is what I
work on.
Oh, was there an RL thing I just missed?
I think it was Lucas Bayer.
Oh, no. He's This is actually fine. when
I reread it.
Okay. So, the thing that I was going to
do here,
um,
Okay, this is a simple check, but I have
to not make a mess of it.
How do you understand the limits of RL?
Now, theory, do you understand the gap
between the theory and practice of RL
right now? The theory of RL basically
gives you nothing. And we are like so
far ahead of that.
The thing if as to how do you make
progress? Um the academic approach has
basically done nothing for the last
decade. In fact, it was so incredibly
ineffective that the uh academia
basically managed to kill their entire
field and now everybody does language
models even though RL is awesome and can
solve so much stuff because
mostly academic myopia. I have articles
on this. Um, the reason that RL is
making progress now is not because of
any new improvements to theory
whatsoever. It's because I made RL a
thousand times faster. So, we can run
Google scale experiments at home and we
can just extensively validate whatever
we want instantly or like almost
instantly. And that lets us do actually
good science whereas the vast majority
of published research in RL is wrong.
That's the actual way progress is being
made Now,
What do one doesn't invalidate the
other? Well, I mean it depends, right?
Like you can do good work in academia,
but the
like RL as a whole, how many papers do
you see with like really simple problems
trained for very few steps with very
fancy algorithms and no hyperparameter
sweeps and really weak baselines. It's
like almost every paper.
um
by comparison, right, by default with
what we're doing. And you can use our
stuff in academic research. You have a
ton of environments. They get to be way
harder than most of what's being used in
academic research. You can train them
for hundreds of millions of steps in
minutes on one GPU. And you can run
automated hyperparameter sweeps with a
state-of-the-art uh hyperparam
optimization algorithm to ensure that
you actually have optimal settings for
both your algorithm and the baseline. So
which of these two like which starting
point is going to produce more accurate
results, right?
You can still do tons of basic science
and stuff, but academia has ignored
performance so much that they have
basically made it impossible to do uh
quality science. That's the main thing
that killed the field.
And a lot of it was like
focus on sample efficiency over
everything else. The experiments just
got slower and slower and slower over
time. Um like you can literally track
this. We had, you know, like a few
thousand step per second training in
2017 or whatever and then it literally
got down to 200 step per second training
in a lot of this stuff that was in like
2022 or three,
but it should have been getting way
faster.
I mean, the amount of things I've seen
that are just like pure pure engineering
fails where you prevent yourself from
doing any quality science because you
failed at engineering so hard. It's just
everywhere, right?
And the problem hyper. So, the reason
that I say it's like academia killed
their own field is because it's baked
into the review system at this point.
Um, like the reviewers are so so
entrenched in this like high sample
efficiency, screw all engineering, like
these classic set of super slow unusable
baseline M like it's just a mess. So
it's almost impossible to publish the
type of stuff that is actually needed to
fix the field. So incentives are
powerful, the field just dies. And uh
most of the people that I know that used
to work in RL, you know, back in 2018,
2019 who were really good, they got fed
up with it and they moved on to work on
language models because it was hard,
brutal, thankless work.
You publish papers where you prove speed
instead of accuracy. Nope, you can't.
I actually I tried this with Puffer Lib
when Puffer Lib was 10 times faster than
everything else. When pufferlib was a
hundred times faster than everything
else, double rejected. I had to make
puffer lib a thousand times faster than
everything else before it would get
accepted.
So think about that. You can publish a
paper where you show our algorithm is
20% better than their algorithm and it
gets published on like some stupid
benchmark that doesn't even transfer to
anything else. But if you try to say,
"Hey, we made all of RL 10 times
faster." You can't get that published.
How [ __ ] up is that?
Like the mindset of the field is just so
wrong.
Theory outside of the norms has the same
problem. Well, that's ridiculous, right?
Academia is supposed to be the place for
new ideas, but it really isn't. And
that's one of the things that I had to
learn. Like literally, you get punished
for going too far outside the norms in
academia.
So like an industry doesn't have the
risk appetite to like do crazy things
most of the time. So pretty much you
just have to do your own stuff outside
of either of those with no external
pressures or stuff doesn't get done.
You got best paper. I got best paper
award hyper. But this was after like
basically fighting the system for seven
years. uh really not getting much
recognition on any of my stuff for any
of the engineering, any of the like
large scale multi- aent stuff I did for
years and then pretty much devoting a
year and a half of my life solid
essentially doing nothing else like
working out and writing this stuff,
thousandxing it. um like the amount of
the amount that you have to pass the
existing by in order to get there is
just completely unreasonable.
And then you know you can go to the same
conferences and you can just walk by the
row of papers and I can just like at a
glance tell you you know
those results are not going to be better
than random on like nine out of 10 of
the papers.
It's a mess.
Academia is a mess.
But it's fine because, you know, I can
build tools that will help with
research. I It's just like
I'm no longer gated by having to publish
stuff. So that's fine by me.
practical stuff. Yeah, I mean that's
pretty much the long and the short of
it, right? Like
there were actually
several pretty damn good projects uh on
like infraside back in the day and they
just didn't get any recognition.
So the authors left. I know one of them,
one of them was at minstrel now having
fun doing uh engineering on language
models because you know the RL community
were a bunch of tools and uh didn't
appreciate his like awesome work.
That's how it is.
Hey Louis, we are working on um the C
vectorization back end with uh async
CUDA buffering. We're trying to do async
buffering host to device device host.
This will be a very very big speed
enhancement if I can get it to work.
Okay, so uh yes, the thing that I was
thinking about here before I went on to
that went on that giant tie raid um
are all equal language. Yeah, exactly.
It's dumb. That's fine.
We'll have the field like well
where it should be within a year or two.
Um,
Ninsky is doing some cool stuff. I know.
I collaborate with them. We uh we ported
their drive in to Huffer and made it 15
times faster.
Trying to think what we do with this.
It's very close. Um
I need to do it's some check on the end
index.
FBR academia will do the opposite. They
will spend a thousand times the wall
clock time to solve it in like half the
number of steps.
Like the wall clock time thing is an
invention of puffer lip. Isn't that
crazy?
Like basically nobody was even looking
at wall [ __ ]
Welcome everybody.
Um, hang on. This is going to get boring
quick if I don't figure out this
indexing. So, let me figure this out
real quick. I just have to check. All I
have to do is come up with a way to
figure out if the uh the observations on
CPU buffer is actually uh ready or not.
Okay. So this is actually not
Yeah. So this is wrong.
So this should be
if
comic
theoretical innovation over engineering.
Yeah, but the thing is they hard
bottlenecked on engineering to the point
that they couldn't make any progress
anywhere else.
Like literally the vast majority of our
published papers are just wrong. The
results are invalid.
I don't have any good way to get this
index actually the way that I have it
like this.
Oh, no. No, I do. I do.
Um.
Oh, yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I totally do. And
like, um
I there's one of them I don't have to
loop over.
Something like this.
Just do
Okay, it's something like this. Let's
now um I'm going to go through this and
we're going to figure out whether I've
like I think I've done this correctly
and then we're going to see if I can get
some of this debugged.
Yeah,
that'll be the goal.
I'm going to use a restroom real quick.
I'm going to see if I can get
maybe another set of three in on the
deadlifts. Maybe. And uh we will
continue
that work index run indefinitely. Yeah,
I think the goal here, Daniel, is um it
should loop. It's a UINT and it's going
to we're going to have it so that it
loops back around safely to zero.
I think that's going to be the goal,
but it's it's kind of a tricky design.
I'm going to have to go through it a
couple times. I'll be right back, folks.
Um and then we will we'll see how far we
get on this. I think if we can get
something that is runnable today, I will
be very happy. That'll be tricky. But we
might be able to do it. And like as soon
as I have this, it's going to be this is
first of all, it's going to be way
faster. And second of all, it's going to
be really easy to test exactly how fast
it is. We'll make like a little C test M
that has onedimensional obs for like
pure throughput. And then we'll make one
that has really big OBS for pure
bandwidth. Be right back.
and we shall see
what I have here. So
uh the design of this thing
the design of this thing is you have a
big bank of threads for running the
environments.
um they're threads, not processes. So
they kind of just like
each thread just grabs the next
environment that needs to be processed
and processes it um all in the same
shared memory. So no stacking, no
copies.
Probably will make it each thread
process it a block of environments
later,
but for now this is good.
And
then there is a main thread. Well,
And then there is a main thread. Well, there's a main like work thread, not the
there's a main like work thread, not the
main thread. Um, and then that thread is
responsible for when you give it actions
and you do an async transfer to uh CPU.
you take GPU actions and async transfer
them to CPU. Uh it will check when that
is done and when that is done it will
tell the worker threads that they can
start processing that block of
environments and when that block of
environments is done it will initiate
the asynchronous
observations to uh GPU transfer. That is
the job of the that thread and that is
pretty much the entire architecture.
So let's see if we've done what I just
described correctly.
We have C thread step.
This thing is going to lock on this wake
mutex.
And
yeah, there's a work index and an end
index.
So when it wakes up, it reads the
current end index
is fine
because you're going to not wake these
up until you've set this
and you're going to set this explicitly
or atomically.
And then what it will do is
it will
add one to the work index
until it gets to end. This is the key
that we filter and it will step this
end.
And technically, if we wanted this whole
thing to busy weight and not have to
lock at all, we could just delete this
and delete this and this could just be
well one,
right?
Cool. Now the thread manager on the
other hand.
The thread manager loops forever
and it goes over all the buffers
and it says if we have actions ready on
the GPU
which is very easy to set this flag and
stream query and the stream is not
blocking.
So that means that the actions are
already on the CPU, right?
Then
we are going to say
that the new end point
is going to be equal to
uh the end index plus the block size
percent with the number of m.
Then we broadcast that.
And is this compatible?
Fetch work index
index less than end.
Actually not a huge fan of how this is.
This wraps weirdly.
Okay. So that we're going to have to go
look at that.
I think pretty much everything that's
screwy is in this thread manager,
but you do set the end index. And then
this this is in the correct order.
And then what we do
is we load up the current work index and
we say hey uh if the current work index
is if it's gone one full block
then we can increment the start index by
a block.
Uh and this relies on the fact that the
work uh the m are always processed in
order. So this is valid.
I think this has to be initialized but
otherwise this is valid.
In fact, let's just do that now.
And then we say obs are ready on CPU
which is true
and then we're going to async copy them
over
and then on send
all that send does is instantiate this
this copy and set this flag to true.
Actions ready on GPU.
Actions ready on GPU. We should set this
to false.
They're no longer ready.
Okay.
uh, we need to set this one, right? So,
we just do OB ready on CPU of buff is
true.
This is roughly the correct design
because
now there's there's a couple places
here. There are a couple places we're
still busy waiting which is awkward but
it's only in the main thread,
the main work thread. Like all the other
workers, they never busy wait.
So, let's go fix a couple very minor
things and we should be able to like
actually try to run this in a second.
See,
buffer
Oh, right. Right. The one thing we
didn't fix is the end index. Let me
think about the end index first. So this
is how we decide whether uh the
environments are done processing their
block uh their chunk of M's.
The easiest thing to do here would just
be to use an int 64 and then never worry
about it. Right?
Why don't we just do that? Let's just
use an in 64 and never worry about it.
Uh
what's the C for atomic 64
okay
T
and this is you
And what we will do
uh what we shall do with this
prevent
this.
So now we no longer have to worry about
all this like circular stuff. Uh it's
just pretty easy.
Should be at least.
Add block size.
That's easy.
Full star this.
And what's this? Buffer
buff.
That should be most of the errors.
find.
So wait, we do source
desk
count
find and stream.
Ah, yes, we need the stream.
That's totally fine.
Uh, yes. Apparently I missed a curly
brace.
incompatible types.
C thread manager takes voidar argic.
null see thread stuff void star veing
void void starh
static void
void are
There we are.
That's pretty cool.
Now, of course, I don't expect this to
run.
And apparently, uh, we have CUDA
crashed.
Docker stop.
Got to reboot the Docker container real
quick.
and of course this is uh going to
deadlock somewhere.
All right. So now we're going to figure
out how we debug this.
Uh this is annoyingly this is threaded
code.
I normally I hate debugging with just
basic prints, but I think that's
actually going to be
I think for threaded stuff that's going
to be like the first level basic thing
that we do, especially with this amount
of threading.
Interesting.
The only print we get.
Let's go turn off
verbose.
There we go.
So, waiting for work.
Okay, so all of our threads started up.
They're waiting for work.
We created eight threads.
We created the back end. Thread manager
starts
thread.
And nobody ever gets assigned a new
work.
Uh, observations ready on CPU needs to
start out true, I believe.
might be ready for the big run. Oh,
let me know. Man,
it's not that expensive to be running
these, so don't worry if it takes a few.
The main thing that would um would save
me time, Jess, is if we get a clean PR
into Puffer 4. And I won't run it with
this janky C++. Like the Python is
stable, right, in Puffer 4. So if we can
run it with like the uh P uh what is it?
Python pufferl in puffer 4
and have the config work out of the box
then like a okay especially if we can if
you can know that it like doesn't crash
um multi uh what is it crash multiGPU or
anything and we can set that all up for
you.
That's the main thing.
Okay, look at this.
Way better, right?
Okay, so this is going to be ve receive.
Cool.
I quite excited for all the selfplay
stuff. I've kind of left that dispenser
in you and I've just been fighting
cuda demons and vec demons and all sorts
of low-level demons, man.
All sorts of low-level demons.
Yeah, I don't like this. But we're going
to do this
honestly.
Just do it right once and be done.
I'm going to have to modify this when we
do multiGPU with this specific version
but not by much.
Ocean and CMS. Yeah, this will be only
ocean and CMS for this back end.
I mean this is basically the nuclear
option.
Ooh,
pretty.
I've been planning to watch it. I'm
going to watch it on stream soon. I got
kind of tied up on this today, though.
I am frankly shocked that that still
trains.
I guess I do only have one buffer, but
like still
How buffered are we? About as buffered
as a puffer.
Yeah. So now we have to modify this
chunk of the code.
Yeah. So now it's it's going to be a
slight change to the C++ as well.
Trying to think how I want to do this.
Uh
[ __ ]
Nice.
Nice
hatch.
Log prop is the same,
but then the reward buffer is different.
Okay.
Uh this is no longer
Joseph's.
Who is on Joseph's stream? What
do you submit any puffer stuff to iClar?
Nope. I don't really publish much
anymore.
kind of hard to do that and all the open
source work.
Go explore will be huge. Yeah,
have something interesting.
Training on the random legalized
position help.
You can try all sorts of stuff like
that.
I have to go for dinner. I'm just going
to see if I can get something that
compiles.
Oh, I just saw your plot. That's
awesome, Jess.
The real ELO plots. That's awesome.
you just dropping by or you got some
stuff to show cuz I'm going to dinner in
like 10 15 minutes.
Honestly, this work has been exhausting.
This one's pretty cool. Like we're
making good progress on this and I can
tell this is going to be awesome when
it's done, but it's complicated.
Definitely complicated.
Sweep seems me for merge. I thought I
merged sweep. What new stuff is there in
sweep?
Yeah. I'm just getting towards the end
of this work block, man.
It's just been like a lot of stuff for a
lot of weeks.
I'm trying to at least get VC done
though before I need to really take a
bunch of time.
What's left for puffer four?
I mean vec optimize mining grew
polish constellation all the
experiments.
There's no way I'm getting it done this
year. It was too optimistic. I mean even
if I like work myself 247.
But it's fine. like we're making we're
still making good progress and like
nothing is going wrong. It's just hard,
right?
We'll just make um if Puffer 4 takes
like longer than the normal 6 months,
Puffer 5 will just be a smaller, you
know, more concentrated update on Go
Explore.
Most likely the case.
the folks have been watching. We
actually had a ton of people today. Um,
I am going to go get dinner in a few.
Tomorrow we have a special stream. I'm
going to be trying out Tiny Grad and
we're going to see whether it's actually
the High Perf Miracle that is claimed
and whether it can do useful stuff for
our kernels. That sounds interesting,
too. All of my stuff is free and open
source right here.
The only way I make money is off of uh
companies. We do custom hyperf sims and
such, custom RL, but all puffer liab. If
you want to help me out for absolutely
free, feed this puffer fish a star. You
like stars, helps me out a ton. And uh
if you want to get involved with
development,
whether that's research side or just
like jam some low-level gamedev and
still contribute to science, Discord is
here.
And other than that, I'm on X. You can
find me here. All my content, including
educational stuff.
Are you gonna watch the interview
tonight, Jess? I think I'm going to
crash and try to get a good day in
tomorrow uh with Tiny and stuff. I said
I will do the um the podcast live at
some point, but I'll do that and I'll
probably post it to YouTube as well,
but for three code will work with four
and five. Yeah. So, there's going to be
a uh a Python
back end that's basically the same as
the current one just with some new
architectures and some perf enhancements
plus constellation. So like new tools,
new sweeps, um new visualization stuff,
speed enhancements, new architecture,
and that's going to be all like simple
Python. And then if you really want max
PF, right, you can run the C++ back end.
That's going to be the idea.
Mhm.
I got a couple minutes.
Quick check on neural MMO here.
still going
doing end games now. Yo, that's pretty
cool, Jess.
So, six GPU makes basically you get 6x
the batch size
We finalized sweeps.
Bit late. Kyouong. Uh I'll review I can
review the PR on stream at some point
either tomorrow or Friday. Um we did
everything that you did before like from
the last couple days. Everything is
merged into three and a four.
Your GU fix worked.
What Gellu fix? Oh, yo, Kvert, did you
have um a GU bug in um the C++ nets or
the C network? Cuz that was a bug in
some version that we like we fixed that.
There was like a very small discrepancy.
Yeah, Kvert. That was a bug that we
patched.
So, if you had like an old uh old
version or whatever,
See, Kung's fix worked. Um, did you get
our cuz we I wrote a patch for that. it.
I think it's in 300. It's definitely in
40.
You can just look the change history on
that file.
This Joseph's commit. Yeah, my bad on
that. That was a really dumb bug. That
was like totally my screw up. It screwed
up the GPU drive ev valves as well. I
had to fix that a while back.
Downloading maps was hassle.
Yeah, drive is a little bit of a hassle,
Kung. And they all like they have new
versions and stuff. I'm actually I'm
chatting with um after Nurups I've got
some stuff planned with their lab.
Anyways,
we'll get like we'll make sure though
before that we get um full 40 in that we
crush their uh you know we crush
whatever their latest model is with 40
We are
15080.
What? Jess
GTX
50.
I mean, like we have all these boxes up
here, you know, these are for
contributors. If you're building stuff,
like we give people SSH access to these
boxes.
If you're building something cool,
actually, if anybody wants to um just go
through the Discord and see who's using
what boxes, cuz I'm sure that there are
people who are no longer using their
boxes um you know, so we can like
reallocate stuff cuz like Jess, you
probably should have a box by now.
Right.
FBR would have a box if he ever PR any
of his cool stuff. Um
I'm box one. Yeah, I know you're using
box one. Hey, Spencer.
Yo, Spencer. Um we're going to
absolutely the the new news is we're
going to absolutely crush vectorization.
It's just going to take some work. I got
to go for dinner in a minute, but we're
going to be able to buffer the like
async buffer all of the CUDA transfers.
So, we're going to pretty much be able
to eliminate I'm I think we're going to
be able to almost eliminate CPU GPU
transfer overhead, which is like the
majority of uh the entire eval loop
right now.
That's the latest news.
Okay, so box two is I forget who's on
box two. And then there's we also have
five, six, and seven.
Cleaning up rocket lander and redoing
physics. PR one of the M's, man. PR a
cool M for access
results. Self trust. Yeah, I've seen
that's pretty cool.
I'm going to go get some uh some dinner
and get some rest. Tomorrow is the Tiny
Grad stream, so I'm going to be live
with that all day tomorrow. pretty much
like good
I don't know at least five six hour
stream on that. Um
and then we will probably resume this
stuff that I'm doing here on Friday.
I think that nothing would change that.
Like even if Tiny is awesome, we're
still going to need Vec. So, and the VC
is going to want to be Cuda. So, yeah.
Anyways, see you all. Have a nice
evening. And uh tomorrow is
Thanksgiving.